-My next guest is a three-time
NFL Defensive Player of the Year
for the Houston Texans.
He also does incredible work
through his charity,
the J.J. Watt Foundation.
Here he is, J.J. Watt!
Ah, come on. Look at you.
-Thank you, my friend.
-Wow. Look at -- Look at --
Just surrounded by awards.
-Yeah. They're all papier-mâché.
I made them myself.
-Oh! Oh, my gosh.
Well, they look real.
-Yeah, thank you.
-The big NFL story
from this past weekend --
Tom Brady's going back
to the Super Bowl.
This time as quarterback
of Tampa Bay.
Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
It's his 10th
Super Bowl appearance.
So, to put this in context,
you were 12 years old
when Tom Brady played
his first Super Bowl in 2002.
We have a photo of
what you looked like then.
That was you
when he was in his first --
-[ Laughs ] Oh, my gosh.
-Look at that guy.
-Yeah, yeah.
No, that was back when my mom
would put a bowl on my head
to cut my hair.
That's how we did it.
I don't know if anybody
does that anymore,
but that was the thing
we did back then.
-That was the way to do it.
A bowl haircut. Absolutely.
-Yeah. But Tom's unbelievable.
I mean, it's incredible
what he's done. It's --
I don't think people truly
understand or appreciate
or can fathom
how insanely difficult it is.
And the guy is just --
He is the greatest of all time.
-I mean, you've gone up
against Brady a bunch of times.
In fact, we have a photo of one
of the hits that you put on him.
Look at this.
-[ Laughs ]
-Look at the --
Zoom in at Brady's face.
Can we get a close-up?
-Here we go.
-He's like, "Ugh! Boy.
This is gonna hurt
when I go down."
-I'll sign that one
and send it to him,
and I'll make sure
that he has that.
He can hang that on his locker
right before he goes
and plays in the Super Bowl,
so...
-This season obviously didn't go
as you hoped it would.
Texas finished 4-12.
And there was a postgame
press conference.
The only reason
I'm bringing this up, J.J.,
is because
there's a press conference
that went viral a few weeks ago
where you were talked about
how you were feeling.
We have a clip.
Let's just take a look at this.
-This is a job. We are getting
paid a whole lot of money.
There are a lot of people that
watch us and invest their time
and their money
into buying our jerseys
and buying a whole bunch
of [bleep].
So if you can't go out there
and you can't work out,
you can't show up on time,
you can't practice,
you can't want to go out there
and win, you shouldn't be here!
There are people every week
that still tweet you,
that still come up to you
and say,
"Hey, we're still rooting for
you. We're still behind you."
They have no reason
whatsoever to. We stink!
[ Sighs ]
That's who I feel
the most bad for, is our fans.
-Was that therapeutic?
-A little bit.
You know, it was -- it was --
Any time an athlete is asked,
you know,
"How do you get motivated
even though your team
is out of the playoffs?"
Or, "How do you
still go out there
and give it
everything you have?"
It always frustrates me
because -- how can you not?
Like, I --
I'll never understand that.
You know, I was a fan.
I grew up in Wisconsin.
Where I obviously watched
the Green Bay Packers.
Win, lose, or draw,
you were wearing that jersey
and you were watching the game.
And I just --
I've never understood the fact
that we're athletes getting paid
an immense amount of money
to play a child's game,
and there's people all over
that support us
and pour their energy in,
and I'll never understand
how you could possibly
not give everything you got.
-There's a lot up in the air
about where the Texans go
from here.
There are reports that your
quarterback, Deshaun Watson,
has requested a trade.
There's also speculation
that I heard
that you could be traded.
How do you process that kind of
chatter and those rumors?
And do you pay attention?
-I process it
by going to Hawaii for a week,
and I probably
should have stayed there.
I probably should have stayed.
It was great.
-Everyone's --
-Lava flows.
-The word doesn't get to Hawaii?
-No. No. No. We --
The word in Hawaii
was "manapua,"
and we were enjoying mai tais
by the pool.
-Yeah.
-So that was a good way for me
to cope with it, and I might
just head back there.
-Your two brothers
play for the Steelers.
We've had them on the show.
There are reports
that the Steelers are interested
in trading for you.
If that were the case, and
there's three Watts on one team,
has that ever happened,
like, even back
when you were on the Pirates or
even back in Pee Wee football?
-No, no. Derek and T.J. have
played together in high school,
college, and the NFL,
which is unbelievable,
but we never all played
on the same team together.
I'm not even sure
if it's physically possible
just from
a bantering standpoint.
Like, somebody would, like,
hide somebody's shoes.
Just, like, childhood games.
-Brothers.
-Yeah. Exactly.
-Yeah.
-Not that we do that.
Not that we do that, Jimmy.
-No, no, no.
I had all three of you
on the show.
We talked about it.
I can see exactly
how much fun you have, man.
Hey, I want to talk
about the J.J. Watt Foundation
because this thing is fantastic.
And you started this back
when you were in college.
Can you talk about
what the foundation does
and what inspired you
to start it?
-Yeah, we started
back when I was in college.
I appreciate you bringing it up.
We started
when I was in college.
I was inspired by Myron Rolle,
who was at Florida State
and had his own foundation while
he was playing college football.
I thought that was incredible,
and it inspired me
to start my own.
And one day I was
volunteering at a school,
and the teacher
was telling me a story
about how a child
robbed his neighbor
with a screwdriver after school.
I said, "Well, doesn't he have
anybody at home watching him?"
And she said,
"He gets home at 3:00,
and his mom doesn't get home
until 5:00."
And I said, "Don't you guys
have sports or anything
after school he can do?"
They said, "Budget cuts
haven't allowed us
to have any sports
after school."
And I just personally took that
as no child should ever suffer
because adults can't afford it.
You know, us as adults, we have
to try and figure it all out.
But kids --
kids have no control.
They shouldn't be suffering
and lacking opportunities
just because
we can't give them to them.
So that's why I started
my foundation.
We've done work in --
I believe it's over 33 states
in the country now
we've donated to, and
there's schools and everything,
and it's been awesome,
and it's been extremely --
We have unbelievable fans
and volunteers who help us out.
-It's so cool that you do that
and that you give back
and make people happy.
Congrats on that.
I always like to bring that up
because it's really cool
that you do that.
-I appreciate that
-J.J. Watt, everybody.
For more information
on J.J.'s charity,
check out jjwfoundation.org.
-I appreciate you, my friend.
Thank you. Have a good week.
-Good to see you.